that was unpleasant
[Music]
I've enjoyed lush I know it's very
expensive but it's great I'm into this
because it sounds like a bath bomb for
your little mouth and I like that I
think this is just a ploy to make
brushing your teeth different it's not
broken don't fix it big toothy tags
I'll tell you it's glittery and I like
that crunch tablet between your teeth
grab your wet toothbrush and brush as
usual then rinse clean okay what are you
just like a vitamin C tablet yeah does
this is like asking for your dog or your
baby just be like a card click on now my
insides are glittery and my poop looks
like gold oh damn this charcoal it's
charcoal and chili charcoal is really
good for you though smells fantastic
I bet it tastes like thank you
why am I doing this why are my Dorner
this is some witch's brew my spit is
still coming out black that was terrible
and then I turned and I looked at you
and it got even more laughs ultra blast
tooth powder okay and it says Bobby it
sounds kind of good to me I gotta be
real oh yeah smells like toothpaste
I love the tooth place for your
toothpaste okay strong strong wasabi
flavor not spicy but wasabi I don't know
any wasabi on this even what oh yeah I
love this background there is the other
one tasted like this as me okay this one
I feel the most like fresh booth berry
tooth powder dad your damn toothbrush
into the pot to apply some powder and
get brushing whoa I feel like this is
something I purchased eclairs yeah
it kind of smells like lotion that you
would get when you're like 13 with
shimmer in it
yes it's like fun dip this is my hair I
wanna look I'm reckoning perfume cuz I
love meat I don't want it
oh my my Irish Catholic upbringing why
so Panama yeah you could probably use
this as a highlighter wait if you're
going to look it's so sugary there's a
time of the day for candy there's a time
of the day for toothpaste it's not at
the same time they're very like health
and morally conscious brand which is
good and I like that the flavors just
work the two terrible bad luck didn't
need to go so crazy with the flavors but
I went so far I like the experimental
nature although this was made by Max I'm
on the work it looks just like a stick
there was my face on we can make